and with the nation still reeling from  that racist mass shooting in buffalo the  u.s attorney general is shining a  spotlight on new efforts to bolster hate  crime reporting they include new  guidelines to help police and community  leaders raise awareness of incidents and  funding to help establish new reporting  hotlines  we are actively pursuing making sure  that you know those that propagate  hate are  and those who act on that hate  face  consequences the naacp releasing its own  response plan calling on the doj and the  ftc to aggressively target  misinformation on social media platforms  that recruit young people to spread hate